YouTube,
any war ends with
an agreement,
and in this case it cannot be avoided either,
the whole question is at what
moment you can conclude an agreement.
Unfortunately,
you cannot conclude an agreement with a person like Putin
at the moment when
he believes that he is stronger
than he can you.  deceive if you need to,
but this will not be an agreement, so if
I am often cited here as an
example of his words regarding
cornered rats,
they say do not corner Putin
because he will become dangerous there
is always a difference between not
cornering a rat and not  to let the
rat drink your blood
at the moment when the rat is cornered
and he understands that all he can
do is escape his black hole and
hide there at that moment Maybe
he should be let go
but at the moment when the rat still thinks
that he is winning
and trying to negotiate with her means
waiting for her to call her goods
so that they bite you to
death,
so, alas, I must agree with
the words of Mr. barrel, surprising
for a European bureaucrat And
this issue will be decided on the battlefield and
not at the negotiating table
[music  ]
Putin's loss in this war with a high
degree of probability
will destabilize his regime
whether it will be possible to change it or not
It depends on many circumstances It
depends on the Russians
dear
and even more important and when this regime
changes but anyway it will change sooner or later
Where will it go next  Russia That is
why we and my colleagues are so
Strongly urging the West not
to build an iron curtain
because the
regime will leave Russia it will remain
and Russia can be part of the solution to
the problems that are now facing the world
they are the problem that we are now
under the Putin regime
in the first place I would  I really wanted the
West,
when making a decision for Russia,
to involve professionals in these decisions and
not just politicians
ha ha When I listen to the ideas that
are moving regarding
sanctions, especially in the energy market,
which I understand, I just
want to grab my head
and what is being done with regard to
ideas  with price restrictions, this is it.
Believe me, this is nonsense, there
are other mechanisms, I will not
take your time now to
talk about them, but
at least listen to the experts
20 years ago when they made a decision on the
energy policy of the West, these
decisions today have turned into those
checks for paying utility bills
what you get is the
result of unprofessional
unprofessional in non-political
decisions about unprofessional precisely in the
understanding of energy specialists
Unfortunately, what I hear now are
both audible and absolutely sound
ideas and in parallel I heard some
absolute nonsense I can’t understand because
I know that  excellent specialists
here, even the UK is a
huge number,
I can’t understand this,
but in response to the answer to the question of what can be
done, the answer is a very simple
weapon
delivered to Ukraine
today for a little more than $ 10 billion,
this alone is nothing compared to those losses
in the energy sector  which
will now be taken out of your pockets
if these weapons were not for 10
billion But for 50 Now the situation at
the front would be completely different
I assure you, understanding Mr Putin I
assure you that today this is what he is
doing with energy blackmail he  be
afraid to create